Alright,
the kid's book idea.
Okay.
So it's called a fish tail.
And what's interesting is,
I hear,
I heard Joe Rogan mentioned this concept before,
but I thought of this all on my own note.
And way before this was even before the Joe Rogan podcast even existed,
I thought of this and wrote this book.
So it's called a fish tail.
So it's a story about a fish and he's in this school and you know,
he's just kind of curious,
kind of eccentric,
but you know,
he's,
he's OIC,
he's a fish kind of young.
And then,
um,
one day he's,
you know,
going,
looking for food or whatever and he gets this worm floating around,
good food,
right?
Warren,
boom.
Get snatched up.
Boom.
It's a fishermen caught them flopping around in the boat,
right?
And you know,
they take a picture of munch and,
um,
they throw it back,
you know,
kitchen release situation.
Um,
certainly comes back and,
and you wasn't gone for what,
two minutes maybe.
So he comes back and he's like,
hey guys,
guess what?
I just got yanked,
you know,
to the surface,
uh,
over the,
you know,
above the surface and um,
and these like weird beings,
UFO sir.
Right,
right.
So that's the thing.
So,
and he was describing him,
he was like,
there's these weird beings.
They,
they,
they didn't need water to breathe.
They had,
you know,
these weird appendages kind of like,
they just weren't anything like us,
but you know,
I saw their eyes but it,
that was kind of it.
And then these,
these flashing devices,
you know,
went off and then they just put me right back and here looking at my little
scar,
I'll even show you.
And they're like,
yeah,
no,
no one believed them.
They were like,
oh yeah,
he's just an eccentric fish.
This,
you know,
there's no such thing as that kind of stuff,
and what,
he got a little scar,
we all have scars from fucking whatever.
But meanwhile that really happened.
Right.
So,
and this will,
the parallel there is of course the UFO,
but just because it doesn't happen to everybody doesn't mean that it's not true
necessarily.
You know,
so like,
you know,
people claim abductions for whatever.
Um,
it does,
it seems crazy.
And I it straight up don't believe it before for other reasons other than,
um,
you know,
you don't believe what abductions.
I don't think that there alien abductions know the,
the,
the stories of,
um,
alien abductions by these people or whatever that get abducted,
allegedly.
I don't believe like that happened to me.
Okay.
That's something we should talk about on the podcast.
Well,
don't talk about it right now.
What happened?
Here's the,
I'm just kidding.
Well,
he,
well,
here's the thing though,
when you say I'm not you,
but when someone says,
I got abducted by aliens,
let me tell you my account.
Um,
those being abducted by aliens and then whatever their account is,
are two different things no matter what.
So they're basically explaining an experience and then giving a hypothesis of
what it was.
Yeah.
And most of the time,
not even a hypothesis,
they're just saying straight up that that's what it was.
They're putting,
you know,
they're,
they're naming that experience in basically verifying it and making it,
um,
like a
there,
they're basically saying that that's what it was there.
They're defining it or whatever.
So in their soul fuck like it's like goats when people say they see ghost,
you didn't see,
you don't even know what a ghost is.
People don't know what a ghost is like in the human,
the human race.
Like what's the ghost?
Some will say,
oh,
it's someone's spirit from they die and then their spirit goes in like lives on
or whatever.
But why would you think that?
Because movies say that because anyone looking into that can tell you that there
is no evidence of that.
And I'm not saying that's what,
that's not what they are.
I'm not saying that.
But you are,
you're over here making that claim that that's what it is.
And then that's what you saw.
So all of all the explanations of your quote unquote experience,
whether you think you're abducted by aliens or ghost,
whatever.
So I'll be put
your account of the experience and what actually happened.
The explanation of that experience are two different things.
So you can't just put an explanation on the experience and all the possible
explanations of your experience.
Okay.
There's literally,
there's infinite,
you lost time,
you got passed out,
you woke up in a field with a scar or whatever and you have these weird
memories,
whatever,
not memories.
They're not even memories.
Typically just what really happened that the real explanation for your
experience.
There's probably a good million of them,
right?
All the way down to you.
Imagine the whole thing all the way down to your lying,
all the way down to you're hallucinating all the way down to you are hung over.
So your brain did this.
You actually got abducted by aliens.
We'll just call that as one of the million.
You went straight to aliens.
And not only did he go straight to aliens,
there's no evidence for that.
There's evidence for people hallucinating.
There's evidence for it.
There's evidence for all these other things.
Then you went straight to the one with no evidence for whatever reason,
you know,
and there's reasons for it.
So you can't be mad at the people.
But that's why it's hard to believe these things,
you know?
But my little kids book,
it kind of puts a little bit of a,
you know,
like,
not doubt,
but kinda like,
but you still can dismiss it,
you know?
Because here's like a,
an analogy that could have,
you know,
helped you believe what I'm saying?
It's do this
free fighting back at yon about like maybe two minutes.
I held it in.
I don't want that to be on video.